[Music]
police and emergency workers cordoned
off an area in central Paris after a
gunman went on a deadly shooting rampage
firing at people in a hair salon Kurdish
restaurant and Kurdish Community Center
eyewitnesses said people ran in panic
we were walking down the street we heard
shots we turned around people were
running left and right after five or six
minutes we went into the hairdressers
and we saw people had stopped a man he
was quite old three people were injured
in the salon
foreign
police arrested a 69-year-old Frenchman
he was known to authorities and had been
previously charged with racist violence
against migrants living in tents in the
city
the individual may have attacked these
tents an investigation started at the
end of 2021 and the individual has
recently been released as news spread of
the shooting people from the city's
Kurdish Community gathered to protest
is not random the killer did it to scare
the Kurdish Community
we don't know how we will go on North
Kurdistan is dangerous but we live in
France in the capital and now it's
dangerous here France's prison condemned
what he called in an odious attack
against Kurds in France earlier the
interior Minister had said the shooter's
motivation was unclear
he was clearly targeting foreigners we
need to know from the judicial inquiry
presided over by the public prosecutor
whether it was specifically for the
Kurds but for the moment there is no
evidence to show that
there was no doubt though in the minds
of demonstrators angry and upset they'd
burned flags and threw rocks
the police have moved in now to try and
clear the protesters because things were
becoming quite violent
the protests subsided but police
remained on standby and investigation's
been opened into the attack and the
interior Ministry says Security will be
increased at Kurdish sites in the
country for some they say it's a welcome
measure but one that comes too late
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Paris